- [Voiceover] Where is the
point on the number line?
Well, here it is, here is the point.
But I'm guessing that
they're asking not literally
just to find it and look at it
but what number is this point graphed at.
Where is this on the number line?
So, one thing we know pretty quickly
is the number is between three and four.
It's greater than three
but it's not quite four.
But to figure out how
much greater than three
we need to know what these
black tick marks represent.
So, between three and four there is
one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, ten equal spaces.
So, each of these distances,
each of these equal spaces,
is one tenth
or one tenth of the distance
between three and four.
It's one out of ten equal spaces.
So, if that's one tenth
and this next space is another one tenth.
And then we have to travel one more tenth
to get to our point.
So, we went three, we know it's three.
Plus,
one, two, three tenths.
Three and three tenths.
Or, let's write this as a decimal,
let's look at it as a decimal.
If we wanted, we could
have our ones place value
and then after the ones,
the decimal and the tenths.
So, for the ones, there's three ones.
And how many tenths did we see here?
There were three tenths.
So, either way we can say
three and three tenths
or three and three tenths.
Our decimal, our point
is 3.3 on the number line.